getting ready for the first game of what
promises to be an
unprecedented season unprecedented year
in
this country and around the world
powerful gestures
and mookie vets with arms with cody
bellinger and max muncie on his
shoulders as he takes a knee
joining the likes of pablo sandoval gabe
kepler mike destromski and
several other players and members of
both the dodgers and giants
organizations
as the players show they are standing up
for social
justice in case you had missed it
clayton kershaw put on the injured list
he will not make the opening day start
tonight it's going to be the young
right-hander
dustin may who originally was not going
to be on the 30-man roster and two eyes
and here comes hunter pens rounds it
slowly up the third baseline
maze got it throws to first dug out by
hudson the inning is over and for the
first time in his career
mookie betts goes to bat as a los
angeles
dodger but the cardboard cutouts here
are just going crazy
that's kind of a look you'd expect on
dodgers faces when mookie [ __ ] comes to
the plate
well we know where his mailing address
is going to be for a dozen years
and that one fouled off at the plate
strike three
no foul they say he missed it ball was
dropped and he's tagged out
so mookie bent strikes out in his first
at-bat as a dodger
here is last year's national league mvp
cody bellinger now he swings and lifts a
high drive down the left field line
moving laterally to his right is
dickerson into foul ground near the
railing reaches out and makes the catch
bumps into the railing and comes away
still holding the baseball
well done by dickerson pablo sandoval
with a big spot in this game early
in the third with no score base is
loaded and nobody out
pablo swings it's a high fly ball left
field pretty deep carrying well peterson
back short of the warning track he'll
make the catch
heineman's going to tag at third and he
will come in to score
sacrifice fly for pablo sandoval the
giants are on the board first but muncie
meanwhile into second
with a double so now mookie betts where
the runner in scoring position
has a chance to tie the game with a base
hit that's grounds one
toward third backhanded by wilmer flores
his long throw all the way across is
right there on target
good pitch from johnny cueto to get
through mookie bets seeger into second
with the double two down [ __ ] hernandez
will try to even this game up if not
give the dodgers a lead this one a
little blooper it's gonna drop
and the dodgers first run of 2020 comes
thanks to a seeger double and a [ __ ]
hernandez
bloop single so now the bases are loaded
with two out austin barnes will come up
swinging a ground ball he got jammed to
third floors is gonna scoop it up and
he'll run to the bag at third for the
force out so johnny cueto did a nice job
there he did
dig deep it's threatening here in a tie
game one to one top of the fifth first
and third one out and here comes
the panda swings and hits the slow
bouncer back to the mound ferguson over
to second for one
now they're going after the runner
between third and home heinemann
breaking late for the plate coming after
him [ __ ] hernandez he tries to tag and
misses
now he flips the ball to turner at third
heinemann diving back to the bag and he
is tagged out
it is an inning ending double play
runners at the corners and here is
seeger
this is where smiley just wants to put
an end to this inning
he struck him out swinging so some drama
here in the fifth inning
bloop single here comes mookie betts who
is over three in this game
has reached base on an error finds a
base hit into left field
but mookie is aboard his first hit is a
dodger
lucky wants that baseball first hit of
who knows how many
has a dodger mookie bats and cody
bellinger quite a one-two combo
in that lineup and they have combined to
set the dodgers up second and third
one down big spot for justin turner slow
roller betts coming home sliding in safe
mookie betts gets that left hand in and
that base running
intelligence gives it a 2-1 dodger lead
second and third two out for tk
hernandez finds one into right field for
a base hit
it's gonna be a two run single dodgers
take a four to one lead
austin barnes will hit with the bases
loaded ground ball
backhanded at second base and beating
the tosses
pollock the dodgers take a run but it's
five to one dodgers
the dodgers take a four to one lead it's
six to one dodgers over the third base
goes turner and with two down here comes
[ __ ] hernandez
hernandez with a fly ball to deep left
field it is way back
and it is gone a home run
his fourth hit of the night all right so
on a team with betts and bellinger and
turner and seeger who had [ __ ] hernandez
as the mvp
two down nobody on and here is joe
mccarthy
joe mccarthy with the ground ball to
justin
turner into the shift on the right side
bravo
comes in and closes the doors the
dodgers are
beating the giants eight to one
they take their magic number 11 opening
day wins since 2008
the most in baseball